when Ellen arson meets people these days
her protest against the deportation of
one of her friends dominates the
conversation people all over the world
still congratulate her when she refused
to take a seat on an airplane she
prevented the man's deportation from
göteborg to Afghanistan even if only
temporarily a live video from the plane
made international headlines Harrison
wanted to draw attention to what she
feels is Sweden's inhumane Asylum policy
we're not giving them a correct legal
procedure that they have the right to we
are the government and the migration
office are doing so much things that
they possibly can used to make sure that
they deport and react as many people as
possible
Harrison belongs to a group that looks
after former unaccompanied minor
refugees from Afghanistan the young
refugees are optimistic that Swedes like
arson are prepared to use simple
disobedience to prevent their
deportation I also should have been
deported I launched an appeal against it
I've been waiting a year for a decision
it might even take another year if I
were to then be deported I will have
lived in Sweden for four years I really
don't know how I would react to that the
arason case has fueled debate on asylum
and immigration in Sweden parliamentary
elections are coming up in September and
surveys show increasing support for
right-wing populists but there are also
those who welcome refugees should put a
stump to immigration we need immigration
in Sweden because we need the workers I
will certainly not vote for any party
that is against refugees and immigration
again the biggest opposition party the
conservative motor Ratana is outraged
over the acclaim Arison has received for
her activism here in Sweden it's not the
government that decides on deportation
but it's the courts
and it's not acceptable for individuals
to define court decisions some 100
decisions but as long as people being
deported to Afghanistan risk getting
killed Harrison says she wants to
continue her work she feels this is her
mission in life so even we get back
stopping the deputation to Afghanistan
then we would probably be still together
and I hope so because they are part of
my life now there's and leaves for an
interview with a British radio station
the debate over deportation to
Afghanistan continues in part thanks to
Ellen arason